eu quero compartilhar com você
é uma ideia de tempo é o tempo do riso
e quando ainda tudo o que imaginamos
compartilhado como o mundo modo que nós
visão ainda estava por existir
e é como se fosse antes do tempo
Esse é o tempo dormir
e onde nós ainda não tínhamos angústia
da certeza
e ainda é mordido
a imensa movimentação de ideia de
recursos de meio para medir o tempo
ainda não espere comentávamos o
sentimento é
o interior de angústia em relação amanhã
o amanhã ele diz respeito a nossa ideia
de tempo o tempo prospectivo esse tempo
que seria como o mapa pressa sempre em
direção a alguma coisa Que Nós
aprendemos a
e como o futuro
é bonito o tempo é uma espiral não é uma
floresta
Oi Ni o nosso pensamento pode
experimentar um estado de suspensão
e como na meditação por exemplo
e quando alguém consegue para a mente e
fazer um exercício de meditação
e essa pessoa pode visitar aquele lugar
[Música]
Nossa certeza sobre o amanhã
o filme Encontro com você hoje nós
marcamos novo encontro amanhã
e nós fazemos esse acordo sobre o ferro
uma
eu vou ver se
é como uma pretensão que nós temos
certeza de que amanhã a gente vai estar
aqui ou vamos estar vivo cumprir esse
programa porque nós nos despedimos
fizeram até amanhã nós estamos
investindo certeza Viva o sol mas
acreditamos que tem amanhã
e nós vamos podemos abusar dessa ideia
do amanhã como viemos fazendo nos
últimos duzentos Anos Antes de alguém
conseguiu lavar outra a expressão tempo
e dinheiro
e seria talvez uma medida de tempo
dinheiro assim como outras coisas
poderiam do tempo
em 2018 antes da gente experimentar a
suspensão em contar o tempo todos os
pontos colocados a uma quarentena uma
quarentena assistente for meses medo
Ah e não a situação Mickey Mouse
passamos a contar os dias
e eles ligar
eu percebo amigos
e o outras pessoas celular estão
passando quem está passando agora eu
tenho tempo bonito esse tempo que eu
o Evoque
e quantos nós fizemos um debate Na
Bienal de São Paulo trouxe o tema não
certeza viva
e me deu a oportunidade de provocar as
outras visões de mundo
se liga também em outras experiências de
tempo
o filme coloquei a imagem o exemplo
é daquelas pessoas que têm na prática da
meditação daqui pudéssemos pelo menos um
certo exercício para alguém mesmo tempo
de pandemia experimentar sair dessa
contagem do tempo dinheiro sem
compromisso e experimentar o seu tempo
interior
e esse tempo
e eles liberam
a afirmação que nós gostamos ter certeza
sobre o amanhã
e o amanhã
e você pode ser presente e virar
desencontro nossa segurança Bom dia hoje
é o presente de agora é o sentido da
palavra
o presente Nós pensamos
no passado futuro nós estamos pensando
sobre o final existe mais ou que não
existe ainda
Com certeza viva é a melhor talvez dança
que a gente possa fazer com experiência
para compartilhar a vida é
é uma constelação de outros serviços em
e não conta o tempo uma mais desumano
e nós podemos convocar um tipo de uma
amizade
a capela os outros seres também sobre a
vida resistência uma árvore quando está
junto Ela pode estar com 80 mas ela pode
estar também com 200 anos
o jogo Amarelo
os grandes sequóias chego a 600/800 uma
prova rosa Carvalho
Além disso para ficar nas árvores mas
não tem validade das não tenho
e contamos o tempo muito mais utilizados
pela nossa segurança e pela nossa
incerteza
e eu queria convidar você a fazer uma
experiência em educação
Oi e aí talvez você possa experimentar
também aqui tá um tempo
o que anterior essa angústia
Olá a todos nós do tempo em que nós
fizemos no mundo hoje diante de Santa
Cruz ameaça de cansaço e
a violência
o nosso ser fica obrigado a buscar
certeza
é mas nós podemos habitar uma boa
a experiência certeza viva porque não
ressaltamos o sentido da vida
e não a garantia da vida
e o amanhã
e ele não está à venda eu queria
convidar você pensar amigo Viva o dia de
hoje viva tudo
bom dia boa experiência de cada dia como
um presente seu dia vai ter sempre
renovado de um presente não a prospecção
do tempo
Ah mas essa esse presente que te
possibilita tanto interior de estar no
mundo da melhor maneira e agora
bom obrigado